Hey hi my name is markiplier you may
know me from anyway I just got done
signing thousands and thousands and
thousands of calendars it was fun times
all around look at all the cuts on my
hand
anyway I have a conundrum see you guys
decided to buy so many calendars that I
have to sign 35,000 of them how many
have I signed so far not 35,000 I have
way more to go so I have a conundrum
either I spread out the entirety of the
remainder of how many calendars I have
yet to sign over the period of maybe a
month or I do the unthinkable I get a
day job
you see these calendars are up in a
factory about an hour away so I have to
get in my car every day every weekday
drive an hour to a factory get there at
8:00 a.m. work until 5:00 and then leave
in traffic to get home unbelievable all
because of you you've officially kicked
me off of YouTube and you forced me back
until the rigors of daily life I'll be
proud of yourself well I just wanted to
inform you of this and ask for your help
in the meantime I will not be able to
make any videos at all so I ask of you
to make videos for me post them all
online or in Twitter under the hashtag
exile markiplier 28 markiplier 'he's
exiled 2018 markiplier exiled today
and tomorrow in 2018 markiplier has been
exiled 2018 pick any of those I don't
want to do this don't do it okay I'll be
back it's not a hiatus